[Música]
sí
y
d
[Música]
quién se va
para mí
y usted
porque seguro que no
es una acción
[Música]
dando
porque todos los van a usar
[Música]
es hermoso
buscaba la forma de arreglar
es muy agresivo
y le pasó unos años buscándola
de encontrar
esa acción para ordinario
en este espacio
y
me dice
estas cosas mayores
[Música]
en este canal
no no
y los destrozos
d
mire
y mental
el mundo
ahora
[Música]
la niña
en el mundo
tardías
o social
para mí
graves
lo que pasa en cada uno
también un hombre
y algo parecido
m
[Música]
y con eso
ah
entonces sentí
la forma de combate
y es cierto
que si nosotros necesitamos
en total
esta es la verdad
estaban dos pasos muy aceleradas cartón
no ser el siguiente
como media más que la felicidad
con nuestras ideas
y hacer acciones
[Música]
para el país
ahora
nuestra
es descansar
de las personas descansamos con ustedes
quizás sentirse menos personas las
personas están urbano
sentir que su autoestima estaba que no
pueden lograrlo
ya sabes
habla de los demás
[Música]
y la vida de él
si yo voy a estar criticando a la gente
[Música]
voy a traer esta tendencia a desarrollar
viento
[Música]
declaraciones
positivas
si yo
para mínimas gracias y tibás
suele ayudar
esta va a llegar a la realidad y esto
nos basta
llega
ya sé que no
para compartir la experiencia
porque mira lo que cambia visión y una
de las formas
orgullosa en este sentido que para eso
nada
voluntaria
de una licencia
mejores
querida queremos
no hay más
sí
[Música]
ah
que tenía miedo a hablar delante de los
demás
[Música]
está bien
en la provincia
[Música]
a casa
dónde
después decía que la tercera es una
organización
voy a hacer venir a hacer un
voluntariado
con niños enfermos con verdad que tenían
enfermedades denominadas
niños décadas
es ahí
soñar
estoy asistiendo
para que así
muy importante
un día mientras
volvía
nunca
estaba una niña
[Música]
unido canadá
soñar
como se decía
tenía los días contados
y en esa base
[Música]
en el equipo
x
[Música]
con la ponencia de edad
la canción
a entregarlas
[Música]
sí señor
y durante todo el día
e
[Música]
y toda la nación
deseaba estar
todas las patrullas de amor con la banda
de la policía
como sobre los demás
y bueno en tu día
podemos experimentar su baño
y pudo ser
cómo sería
en ello estamos
cerca
[Música]
y como están conmigo
por un día policía que fue a preguntar
amigos vecinos
[Música]
pero con ustedes
sabe
pero los niños
en la logística de la organización
no tenía obviamente no soy
quizás más largas
y nada
[Música]
la venta
él
en el país
sí
[Música]
y
se suele
[Música]
por qué
sí
en tierra
y el amor
y le hizo todos los otros
todos los males los policías
[Música]
fue el que se encargó de todos
iniciaron los lugares
y
la oración
en todo mundo larga
e
y bueno
[Música]
el día
viéndolo
y el de una planta
a conocer
y para dejar más especial
porque todo
la verdad
y seguro
en usted
y
ya se está arriba
[Música]
también es así
nadie
carrión
y ahora me ha cambiado la vida de las
voluntarias y
según los cuales la familia de la
trinidad
por qué
voy a volar
sí
[Música]
hay muchos niños que están bien
niños organza
ah
y estos niños son niños
a ellos se vayan felices
y
y así
[Música]
y además
en mi ciudad tenemos
mis niños
indican también este día estos días de
invierno
[Música]
esta decisión
d
un día
muchas gracias
nunca
no
qué
cuando nosotros como voluntarias
quisimos evitar
no tenemos
ya después son acciones
[Música]
tengo enfrentado con tareas que han
decidido comprometerse
para poder cambiar
la misma
significa
en terminar
y visitar
la madre
[Música]
por eso
desde
la realidad tampoco
hemos visitado hospitales
y energía
pero los olores
también los que no necesitan
que nosotros les apoyemos económicamente
que sí es muy importante
[Música]
necesitan más humanos
ellos necesitan más un abrazo en lugar
de dos
visitarás
necesitan las acciones por parte de
estos
a otras
el día en que murió
en este caso los dos últimos años
hola
en el área
[Música]
son niños que trabajan
amigos
para poder
este día
ellos qué
bien como tenía que cantar y al escalar
y las habitaciones que están allí para
mirar
presenciamos de muestra material de
dólar
este material
no necesitamos
identificar a los alejados
[Música]
visita
también el mismo una lección
miramar
[Música]
y aquí está
son reales
de nuestra ciudad
y adhesiones
qué hacer
tratamiento para
venga ya
y desgracias
i
las experiencias que vamos a mirar
d
nosotros
y entonces muy competida de los niños
sufren
cuando nos encontrábamos en una
actividad y un niño
[Música]
ella entendió cómo
quisiera experimentar
y ahí el cantante también nuestro de la
misma
puedes manejar la caridad
también sé
y mucho
pero nosotros como voluntarios les
estamos dando las opciones para hacerlo
estoy segura que cada uno
tienen
como agregar
pero no somos las pequeñas acciones
lo que haré
que sea
[Música]
una fundación así todavía
pero la realidad
no creo en la necesidad
animales
a jugar
[Música]
el día
se ha iniciado
estamos madres
con cada
no
[Música]
y ellos
y en cada día
mis valores
de darles una opción de vida
[Música]
y
complican
puedo decir
y usted
cómo me están escuchando
nota qué
si quieres tienes
en acciones
ahora porque todo se puede
el mundo
y yo hablamos aisladamente
ah
i
en las obras
en esta estación
al venir
hay muchas experiencias
las personas que han vivido o tras la
transferencia
para
cada día
y tal vez
el día
de todas maneras será la iniciativa con
santidad
es una clave
no
así como
ya no solucionando
conmigo 40 voluntades y en el día del
niño
hacer acciones para mí y todo eso
comienza